[Music]
so your bebe Rexha will be at the MTV
VMAs on the 20th that's right she's
nominated for best collaboration for her
song meant to be I love this song
featuring Florida Georgia line well she
is in Kelton I found out miss Rexha is
officially a crossover hit first let's
talk about your record-breaking success
pi longest-running country hit of
all-time bursts were the first to
celebrate together yeah it was like kind
of like meant to be it's like I'm so
corny but it was 28 year old bebe Rexha
is having a moment she's with Nick Jonas
Bruno Mars and Katy Perry who had the
most rigorous fitness routine while
touring Katy Perry who had the biggest
tour bus Katy Perry was most demanding
Katy Perry what is it Katy that you love
so much she is like a firecracker she's
just amazing Beebe has topped
Billboard's Hot Country Songs chart for
35 weeks with meant to be but what you
may not know she's the mastermind we had
some really big hits you're actually be
be the hit maker
oh really cool title thank you so I want
to go through like some of these songs
that you've written that are massive
smashes first monster with Eminem
what's going through a tough time and I
found this quote on the internet that
said we stop looking for monsters
underneath our beds when we realize that
they're inside of us at that time nobody
would answer my phone call nobody wanted
to get into this studio with me but I
wouldn't give up hey mama with David
Guetta and Nicki Minaj yeah that was a
smash
so we go in and then we just write hey
mama and it's like literally in 15
minutes the the hook me myself and I
that was my first like real like moment
where I was like because I got the
proper feature cred and was a music
video is really special
[Music]
now baby's got an album all her own
called expectations but you wanted to
know about this is there an engagement
they say you're wearing an engagement
ring the most secret I love her I wish
this is just my ring that's my manager
bought me for my birthday this would be
on it so yeah you know like I've been
reading those beams like everybody's
getting engaged and married and it's
like some unique Priyanka Justin hailey
Ariana and Pete but I am not engaged
unfortunately I can't even get a text
back so my takeaway from all this is
it's good to be baby right sure head
he's doing it all right she also
recently took home freshest new artist
and favorite country song at the ring of
Disney Music Awards which are all voted
by fan
[Music]